gerade das getan hat 77 jahre nach dem
ende des zweiten weltkriegs die
russischen truppen rücken von mehreren
seiten vor es herrscht wie der krieg
mitten in europa
vierundzwanzigster februar
2022 russlands brutaler krieg gegen die
ukraine schockiert die welt und der
westen besinnt sich auf ein altes
bündnis die nato
präsidentin präsident putin will weniger
nato er bekommt mehr nato die russen
gaben alles sie rücken und spalten
viele hatten die nato abgeschrieben
donald trump hielt sie für überflüssig
emanuel makro erklärte sie für hirntot
und ihren einsatz in afghanistan
beendete die nato nach 20 jahren im
totalen chaos
es gab ein echtes fragezeichen auf diese
nato sich noch einmal einigen und für
ein gemeinsames ziel arbeiten kann
der angriffskrieg von putin gibt dem
verteidigungsbündnis zurück was es
zuletzt dringend suchte einen zweck und
neuen zusammenhalt
kürzlich ging es wieder um die
verteidigung der freiheit plötzlich war
klar wofür es die nato gibt
wie reagiert die nato auf putins krieg
und wie einig ist sie auf dauer
[Musik]
unterwegs im süden von litauen hinter
dem zaun liegt russland
wir treffen algirdas merke videos der 69
jährige pflegt die erinnerung an die
geschichte
er ist lehrer in pension
diese gegend sei schon immer grenzland
gewesen die staaten wechselten die
grenze blieb seit 600 jahren so hat er
es in den stein meißeln lassen wir
fragen was er fühlt wenn putin in europa
wie der grenzen verschiebt mit gewalt
sie meinen die russen könnten auch
hierher kommen wir haben auch unsere
grenzschützer
sehen sie die nato hat uns bislang nicht
im stich gelassen
ich denke sie würde uns schon retten
nirgends ist die nato so verletzlich wie
an dieser stelle des bündnisgebietes
bisher unveröffentlichte aufnahmen
sollen zeigen die russische flugzeuge
mehrfach in den nato luftraum über dem
baltikum eindringen nur eine provokation
estland lettland und litauen sind
nato-mitglieder umgeben von russland
dessen verbündeten belarus und der
russischen exklave kaliningrad
dazwischen liegt die sogenannte suzuki
lücke ein russischer angriff hier würde
die baltischen länder von polen
abschneiden also vom übrigen nato gebiet
das ist nur ein szenario aber eins auf
das sich die nato vorbereitet
die litauer haben ihre erfahrungen mit
moskau im januar 1991 noch vor dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion wollen sie
ihre freiheit moskau schickt panzer 14
menschen sterben hunderte werden
verletzt damals steht vytautas
landsbergis an der spitze der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung sein enkel neun
jahre alt wird in einem krankenhaus
versteckt und ist heute
litauens aussenminister
das krankenhaus lag an einer der
hauptstraßen ich hörte die schweren
motoren und das rollende panzer auf den
straßen
das geräusch bleibt in dir drin
metall auf asphalt du erkennst es immer
wieder
mittels
wenn ich heute kriegsgebiete sehe dann
weckt das bei mir erinnerungen
die geschichte prägt die politik
baltische staaten verlangen stets mehr
härte gegenüber russland als andere
schon als putin seine truppen versammelt
rückt die allianz der 30 eng zusammen
als der krieg dann beginnt erst recht
die us-botschafterin erlebt die nato in
kriegszeiten von innen
[Musik]
ich bekam einen anruf um vier uhr
morgens russische truppen hatten sich
über die grenze zur ukraine bewegt
vier stunden später gegen 8 uhr
versammelten sich alle 30 alliierten
hier zu einem sondertreffen des
nordatlantik grad es fühlte sich fast
routiniert an weil wir so viel zeit in
die vorbereitung genau dieses szenarios
gesteckt hatten
und das beruhigte ich denke vor allem
die länder in osteuropa die nun wussten
dass sich die sicherheitslage dramatisch
verändert hatte und es beruhigte
hoffentlich auch unsere freunde in der
ukraine dass die allianz sich sofort
zusammensetzte
sie treffen sich hier im herzen des
brüsseler hauptquartier seit
kriegsbeginn so oft wie selten zuvor
vertreterinnen und vertreter der nato
staaten der generalsekretär einige
mitarbeiter abgeschirmt von der
außenwelt was die besprechen bleibt
streng geheim wie soll das bündnis auf
putins krieg reagieren wie stärkt es die
eigene verteidigung wie unterstützt es
die ukraine militärisch ohne in den
krieg hineingezogen zu werden
russlands krieg lenkt die öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit wieder auf das was hier
passiert auch in deutschland dass die
nato angesichts des ukraine krieges für
die sicherheit deutschlands viel
wichtiger geworden ist sagen 62 prozent
der deutschen nur 34 prozent meinen dass
nichts
marriott forscht zur jüngsten geschichte
der nato
über sicherheit denkt niemand nach bis
sie bedroht oder verschwunden ist
putin begeht kriegsverbrechen wirklich
schreckliche taten aber
es hat doch etwas klasse kleines gutes
der westen erkennt den wert von
zusammenarbeit
zusammenarbeit heißt für die nato mehr
truppen an der ostflanke deutschland
sonst für zögerliche unterstützung der
ukraine hart kritisiert recht bei der
bündnisverteidigung voran im juni ist
der kanzler in litauen diese nato kampf
gruppe steht unter deutscher führung die
bundesregierung erhöht die truppenstärke
in litauen und will in deutschland eine
vierstellige zahl von soldaten bereit
halten zur schnellen verlegung
wir werden jeden zentimeter des
territoriums gemeinsam mit unseren
verbündeten verteidigen wenn sie
angegriffen werden
was so selbstverständlich klingt ist
eine neue strategie vier monate zuvor
ebenfalls in litauen wachwechsel bei der
nato kampf gruppe noch gibt es keinen
krieg noch gilt die alte strategie die
des sogenannten stolperdraht demnach
hätten diese soldaten die aufgabe einen
möglichen russischen angriff nur zu
bremsen erst dann käme die rückeroberung
[Musik]
diese verstärkte vorne präsenz so der
nato-sprecher war die antwort auf
russland seien aktion der ukrainischen
halbinsel krim
2014 und den baltischen staaten war das
nie genug litauens präsident will mehr
nato stiefel auf seinem boden er dankt
und drängt
um den abschrecken in unserer region
aufrecht zu erhalten und den frieden zu
schützen
abschreckung und verteidigung die nato
rüstet auf bisher stehen nato
kampftruppen in estland lettland litauen
und polen sie werden verstärkt und neue
kommen dazu in der slowakei ungarn
rumänien bulgarien
wie groß sie werden der nato gipfel in
madrid entscheidet der stolperdraht
reicht nicht mehr nicht nach food ins
krieg in der ukraine
wir müssen uns darum kümmern wie wir das
nato gebiet verteidigen
in der super league liegen große
litauische städte denken sie an die
bilder der städte ringsum kiew als ihr
zurückerobert worden
wenn sie das auf litauen anwenden dann
ist das ein sehr beängstigendes bild
wir brauchen die sicherheit dass wir uns
mit allen mitteln die nötig sind
verteidigen können
moskau im mai
2022 wladimir putin der herrscher im
kreml erzählt seine sicht der geschichte
und darin ist die nato eine bedrohung
für russland
die nato begann mit der militärischen
erschließung der an russland
angrenzenden gebiete so hat sie
systematisch eine für uns völlig
inakzeptable bedrohung geschaffen direkt
an unseren grenzen
die nato habe sich immer weiter
ausgedehnt und damit ein versprechen
gebrochen
putin stützt sich vor allem auf eine
aussage
februar 1990 treffen der außenminister
der usa und deutschlands
sie erklären gemeinsam
wir glauben dass es zum teil
bestandteil
ein
stabilitäts partnerschaft zwischen west
und aus die mit dem osten anbieten
können gehört dass die nato sehr klar
macht dass war es immer im warschauer
pakt geschieht nicht beabsichtigt ist
die nato nach osten auszudehnen
doch genau das passiert nachdem der
warschauer pakt 1991 zerfällt nimmt die
nato ab 1999 zwölf staaten auf viele
gehörten einst zu moskaus militärbündnis
manche waren teil der sowjetunion
doch den nato beitritt ist ihr eigener
wunsch
putins sicht der geschichte aber kennt
keine freie bündnis war und lässt
historische fakten außer acht denn die
berühmte aussage von genscher wurden
offizielle politik gegenüber moskau
warum es ergänzt das problem war
genscher als außenminister hatte das
nicht zu entscheiden das waren die
regierungschefs also der damalige
kanzler helmut kohl und us präsident
george bush beide hatten eine andere
meinung als bush und kohl hörten dass
genscher und andere über dieses
versprechen diskutierten wurden sie sehr
wütend und wollten das verhindern
tatsächlich schrieb kohl sogar einen
brief an genscher dies sei nicht die
position der deutschen regierung er
sagte es ihm nicht nur sondern schrieb
ihm einen brief den ich im archiv des
deutschen außenministeriums gefunden
habe die mär vom versprechen ärgert auch
den ehemaligen deutschen
verteidigungsminister thomas de maizière
es kann nicht ein deutscher
außenminister heimlich
die baltischen staaten oder polen daran
hindern in freier selbstbestimmung zu
entscheiden welchem bündnis sie angehört
angehören wollen nachdem wir das durften
die vorstellung dass wir deutschen
unsere schäfchen ins trockene bringen
und anschließend mittel und osteuropa
sozusagen im einflussgebiet russlands
bleiben was ist denn das für eine
vorstellung von europäischer sicherheit
und freiheit
hätte es dennoch möglichkeiten gegeben
zur verständigung mit russland
wir sind im archiv der nato als erstes
kamerateam dürfen wir hier filmen wir
finden fotos vom ersten besuch eines
nato-generalsekretärs in moskau nach dem
kalten krieg der deutsche manfred werner
trifft michael gorbatschow
damals wirken diese bilder hoffnung man
glaubt an dauerhafte geregelte
zusammenarbeit wenig später sogar auf
basis der sogenannten nato russland
grund akte
und auch als im jahr 2000 vladimir putin
an die macht kommt
ich erinnere mich sehr gut an mein
erstes treffen mit präsident putin im
frühjahr 2001 er war neu als präsident
ich war neuer premierminister von
norwegen wir trafen uns in moskau und
ich erinnere mich an unseren optimismus
dass wir jetzt da der kalte krieg zu
ende und die chaotische zeit in russland
vorbei sind eine neue partnerschaft
begründen können zwischen russland und
norwegen zwischen dem westen und
russland im allgemeinen
war der glaube an zusammenarbeit mit
putin naiv
nein es war absolut richtig einen
versuch zu unternehmen zu schauen was
möglich war
was war möglich nato gipfel in bukarest
2008 die usa wollen der ukraine und
nebenbei auch georgien eine konkrete
beitrittsperspektive anbieten
deutschland und frankreich sind dagegen
halten das risiko einer konfrontation
mit russland für zu groß
was am ende herauskam war ein kompromiss
der das schlechteste von beiden seiten
vereinte das abschlusskommuniqué des
gipfels enthielt zwar einen satz wonach
die ukraine und georgien nato-mitglieder
werden aber die allianz unternahm keinen
einzigen schritt um das wahr werden zu
lassen
ich denke dass die nato damals die
strategische geopolitische vision
verloren hat ihren sinn und die frage
bleibt hätten wir ernsthaft über einen
weg nachgedacht wie man die ukraine in
das bündnis aufnehmen kann oder
zumindest sicherheitsgarantien erweitern
kann vielleicht hätte das diesen krieg
verhindert vielleicht hätte das tausende
von menschenleben gerettet
ich halte das nicht für richtig
vielleicht hätten wir da noch einen
größeren krieg vor allem waren die
ukraine und georgien zu dem zeitpunkt
überhaupt nicht der beitritt reif es
waren keine gefestigten demokratie das
meiner sicht hätte man vielleicht härter
sagen müssen die ukraine soll nicht teil
der nato
aber zum damaligen zeitpunkt hatte es
eine schwere krise der nato überwunden
die ukraine wurde also nicht mitglied
der nato und wird es auf lange sicht
wohl auch nicht werden russlands angriff
in diesem jahr ist also kein bündnisfall
die nato wenig partei werden in diesem
krieg es ist ein balance akt nicht als
nato zu handeln und der ukraine trotzdem
zu liefern was sie braucht
meine agenda ist ganz klar sie besteht
nur aus drei punkten
waffen also ein dankes video der
ukrainischen streitkräfte für diese
cesar haubitzen aus frankreich nicht die
nato schickt waffen sondern die
einzelnen staaten ist dass der ausweg
aus dem dilemma
rammstein der us-militärstützpunkt in
deutschland ende april die usa laden 140
nationen wollen hier mit dem
ukrainischen verteidigungsminister über
waffenlieferungen sprechen es entsteht
die ukraine kontaktgruppe ein forum
bewusst jenseits der nato
doch die feine trennlinie verschwimmt
mitte juni treffen der
nato-verteidigungsminister im
hauptquartier in brüssel kurz vorher
sitzen sie als ukraine kontaktgruppe
zusammen dasselbe gebäude fast dieselben
personen nur nato darf es nicht heißen
dass zu erklären wird immer schwieriger
nun schauen sie wir haben doch eine
tradition dass in der nato manchmal
treffen stattfinden zu denen einzelne
verbündete einladen in diesem fall
führen die usa einen prozess an um die
militärische hilfe für die ukraine zu
koordinieren die usa führen die usa
laden ein
was braucht die ukraine wer liefert was
es wird das thema des westens in diesem
krieg die einen wie die usa schicken
sehr schnell sehr viel
andere wie etwa tschechien liefern früh
auch schwere waffen wie diese panzer
sowjetischer bauart und schließlich sind
all jene die zögern und dafür heftig
kritisiert werden deutschland höchst
sich nur langsam von seinem glaubenssatz
keine waffen in kriegsgebiete und hat
sowieso nicht viel auf lager
die ukraine wünscht sich diese marder
schützenpanzer der bundeswehr die
bundesregierung aber verweigert die
lieferung aus sorge in den konflikt mit
der atommacht russland hineingezogen zu
werden doch je länger der krieg dauert
desto schwerer und moderner werden die
waffen aus dem westen im juni erklärt
der nato generalsekretär das altes
sowjetisches gerät nicht mehr ausreicht
spector hatte somit ich erwarte dass wir
auf dem gipfel in madrid ein umfassendes
hilfspaket beschließen werden um der
ukraine beim übergang zu helfen
von sowjetischer ausrüstung zu solcher
nach modernen westlichen standards
rote linien verschieben sich auch durch
diese bilder hasford butscher anfang
april
kriegsverbrechen so unerträglich dass
sie politik verändern und politiker
bewegen
kurz darauf ein nato treffen mit gast
aus der ukraine die minister sind für
ein team mit gefühl aber gespalten in
einer grundsätzlichen frage kann
russland je teil einer friedensordnung
werden
ich denke nicht dass es einen platz für
putins russland in einer europäischen
sicherheitsarchitektur gibt
diese person wird in vielen hauptstädten
der allianz als gesprächspartner
akzeptiert und bei geht völkermord oder
verbrechen in der ukraine
ich weiß nicht wie man mit einem
staatschef redet der völker motto
politik am langen tisch so wie vor dem
krieg anfang februar nahm immer nur
kronplatz und neun tage vor kriegsbeginn
auch olaf scholz mit putin reden darf
man das muss man das auch jetzt noch
stolz und micron telefonieren mit dem
angreifer auch während des kriegs schuld
sagt man überbringe klare botschaften
micron sagt putin dürfe sein gesicht
nicht verlieren es ist eine haltung die
viele entsetzt wie den ehemaligen
finnischen premier alexander
steen ist eine schande für die
internationale gemeinschaft weil er
aggressiv ein unschuldiges souveränes
land angreift und frauen und kinder
abschlachtet
wie zur hölle soll er dann nicht das
gesicht verlieren
er hat es schon verloren
makro und scholz sollten das nicht
vergessen
mitte juni eine reisegruppe auf dem weg
nach kiew sie kommen spät aber sie
kommen die italiener mario draghi der
franzose emmanuel makro der deutsche
olaf scholz was sie auch hier hin
begleitet ist die frage ob ihr dialog
mit putin wirklich sein muss die
rechtfertigung übernimmt emanuel makro
[Musik]
das ist eine frage des nutzens das ist
ein wichtiger punkt den man
unterstreichen sollte am ende werden
diese gespräche stattfinden müssen
es gilt das alte sprichwort mit freunden
schließt du keinen frieden du musst mit
deinen feinden reden so sehr wir also
putin verachten müssen wir dennoch mit
moskau ins gespräch kommen ich mache mir
sorgen weil wir jetzt sehr schnell zum
kalten krieg zurückgekehrt sind aber zu
einem ohne die leitplanken die wir
früher hatten ohne rüstungskontroll
verträge
es ist also jetzt eine sehr gefährliche
zeit für die welt und der einzige ausweg
ist so traurig es ist der dialog
die allianz mark streiten aber in der
krise wird sie noch attraktiver für alle
die draußen sind
das ist der so genannte service tunnel
auf diese gelben vierecke sollen
toilettenkabine kommen
[Musik]
helsinki ein sicherheitsmann führt uns
durch einen bunker unter der hauptstadt
einen von vielen die es hier gibt und
die immer noch ausgebaut werden
finnland blieb lange militärisch 0 3
wollte nie teil der nato werden doch der
krieg den der nachbar russland begonnen
hat führt zu einem historischen umdenken
das kaum einer erwartet
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass es jemals dazu
gekommen wäre hätte putin nicht die
ukraine angegriffen
vorher waren in umfragen 50 prozent
gegen einen beitritt und nur 20 dafür
das hat sich über nacht geändert für
finnland und schweden war die
schlussfolgerung nach den 24 februar
ganz einfach wenn putin seine slawischen
brüder und schwestern in der ukraine
abschlachten kann dann kann er es auch
anderswo tun
schweden und finnland zwei mustergültige
demokratien mit leistungsfähigen ami von
ihrem beitritt würde auch die nato
selbst profitieren findet der ehemalige
us-verteidigungsminister leon panetta
schweden und finnland dabei zu haben das
stärkt die nato
wir begrenzen russlands macht und das
war ja der eigentliche zweck der nato
als beide staaten im mai ihre bewerbung
abgeben ist aber kaum jemandem nach
feiern zumute da nämlich hat sich einer
schon quergestellt recep tayyip erdogan
autoritär regierender präsident der
türkei die seit 1952 der allianz 1
gehört
keiner von den beiden staaten hat doch
einen klaren standpunkt gegen
terroristen
was er wirklich will bleibt lange unklar
geht es um härte gegen die kurdische pkk
oder um us amerikanische kampfjets die
bekommt die türkei seit 2009 10 nicht
mehr weil sie damals zusätzlich ein
russisches raketenabwehrsystem gekauft
hat
29 nationen wollen die schnelle
erweiterung eine blockiert vorerst
einigkeit und glaubwürdigkeit stehen auf
dem spiel
man kann demokratien nur glaubwürdig
verteidigen wenn man selbst demokratisch
ist und deswegen wird es immer eine
herausforderung sein mit kritischen
staaten die
probleme mit demokratischer
zuverlässigkeit haben umzugehen dieser
herausforderung muss sich der
nato-generalsekretär stellen per telefon
per reisediplomatie mitte juni ist jens
stoltenberg zu gast beim finnischen
präsidentin und geht in finnland auf die
türkei zu
keine kritik eine erdogan stattdessen so
viel lob wie selten
ist es das sind berechtigte bedenken es
geht um terrorismus um waffenexporte wir
müssen verstehen dass kein anderer nato
staat so viele terroranschläge erlitten
hat wie die türkei
und dass die türkei ein wichtiger
verbündeter ist mit einer strategisch
wichtigen lage
dem zugang zum schwarzen meer und den
grenzen zu irak und syrien die türkei
hat eine schlüsselrolle gespielt in
unserem kampf gegen terrorgruppen wie
den islamischen staat
ist die nato zurück die veto drohung der
türkei führt der welt vor augen die neue
stärke ist zerbrechlich in einer allianz
die alles einstimmig entscheiden muss
kann einen quertreiber in den eigenen
reihen alles zunichte machen
und was wenn in den usa wieder jemand
gewählt wird der die nato für
überflüssig hält wir
sind ein land in dem die polarisierung
sehr stark ist
aber aktuell gibt es in der frage ob man
in der nato zusammen arbeitet um putin
in der ukraine die stirn zu bieten zum
glück große überparteiliche zustimmung
doch die herausforderung wird sein
unsere einheit zu erhalten unseren
willen zur zusammenarbeit zu bewahren um
nationale sicherheit zu gewährleisten
noch einmal treffen wir jens stoltenberg
seit 2014 der generalsekretär der nato
eigentlich wollte er das amt in diesem
jahr abgeben und in seiner heimat
norwegen die zentralbank leiten er ließ
sich zum bleiben überreden
die spitze wechseln mitten in dieser
krise das risiko schien vielen zu groß
putins krieg hat alles verändert die
nato und seine karrierepläne
ich achte nicht so sehr auf mein
vermächtnis aber man wird sich erinnern
an den größten wandel der nato seit ende
des kalten kriegs
wir nehmen wieder unsere wichtigste
verantwortung wahr die für die
gemeinsame verteidigung von europas
und wir haben demonstriert dass wir
trotz aller schwierigkeiten auch damals
unter der präsidentschaft von donald
trump die nato als die erfolgreichste
allianz der welt erhalten konnten
litauens grenzen vertrauen sie auf das
alte neue versprechen der nato ein
angriff auf einen ist ein angriff auf
alle die beistandspflicht
frage in einen grenzschützer fühlen sie
sich sicher
ja denn hinter mir steht jemand der im
ernstfall hilft
dieser jemand das ist die nato im
angesicht von putins krieg will sie an
den grenzen ihres bündnisgebietes stärke
abschrecken um den ernstfall zu
verhindern
kämpfen muss die nato trotzdem jeden tag
um ihre neu erlangte einheit zu bewahren
[Musik]